well the government shutdown has ended
and we're quickly learning more and more
about why Donald Trump has sort of been
all over the place on what it would take
to end the government shutdown and it
appears that it all along had everything
to do with John Kelly and Stephen Miller
and I told you before that Donald Trump
at one point said hey I would do a clean
dhaka bill said it - Dianne Feinstein on
national TV then backed off of that then
at another point Donald Trump said oh I
would sign any bipartisan legislation
that lands on my desk to avoid a
shutdown but then he refused to sign a
piece of bipartisan legislation that
actually did land on his desk at another
point he said that his us-mexico wall
must be part of the daka approval but
then that went away and now there's a
great new report from the New York Times
that at least partially explains what's
going on it was all along Donald Trump's
elegant chief of staff John Kelly and by
the way the reason I say that is there's
this really weird interview from a
couple months back where Trump kept
referring to John Kelly as being elegant
and it was just so good and we never
figured out why but now I call him the
elegant John Kelly not surprising he is
an elegant guy oh yes I guess it's not
it's not inaccurate it's just weird that
- what Trump is focused on so the
elegant John Kelly and Trump's
outrageous policy advisor Stephen Miller
have been pushing Trump to just keep
going demanding extreme immigration
policy before relenting on the shutdown
of course that ultimately didn't happen
the shutdown has been ended even
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham has
pointed to Stephen Miller as just being
an obstacle to ending this entire thing
saying quote as long as Stephen Miller
is in charge of negotiating immigration
we are going nowhere he's been an
outlier for years it actually might be
that Trump is being exploited here by
his staff because it's been clearer and
clearer to me that Trump all along did
want to end the shutdown and sort of was
confused about why they couldn't um
confused about many things but one of
the things he was confused about was why
they couldn't end or have avoided the
shutdown but it's his own team that was
pushing him to keep it going and this
actually relates to the topic of leaks
Michael Wolf's book fire and fury says
straight up that part of the reason for
the leaks that are just endless coming
out of the Trump administration is that
the leak sometimes function is a better
way to actually talk to Trump so to
speak in terms of actually talking to
him if you go to Trump as Michael Wolfe
suggests if you're in Trump circle inner
circle staff whatever and you try to go
to Trump directly and say hey here's
what we should do or that's what we
should do it might work but if someone
gets to trump two minutes later and says
do this other thing then Trump's gonna
go with that other thing as we know if
you use the leaks to filter through the
media and back to Trump with the optics
that Trump often doesn't like around
media reporting it almost might be a
better way to get Trump to go along with
what it is you want him to do and that's
really a bad thing because remember
Trump doesn't really have like a
hard-and-fast personal policy philosophy
nor does he really care - he's focused
with optics he's focused on deal making
period and other than not Obama right
we've talked about just doing anything
that Obama didn't want or reversing what
Obama did Trump will more or less go
with anything if framed correctly and
coming from the right person and what's
increasingly both sort of mind-boggling
and scary
is how much influence Stephen Miller has
over Donald Trump and by proxy how much
influence Stephen Miller has over the
national course of politics we shouldn't
understate how much Trump's desperation
to just go play golf can also be used so
imagine the scenario that that's going
on Pat you have people in the White
House who know one of the best ways to
get action from Trump is to leak to the
media to trigger reports that Trump
won't like and will get him to act
erratically combined with the fact that
if Trump hasn't been able to go golfing
for a few days as we saw he was forced
quote forced to stay in Washington DC
because of the shutdown
past weekend his desperation to just do
anything to get back to golfing will go
way way up yeah and this is how the
president is deciding how much do I want
to go golfing and what messages are
coming through the media that I want to
end as a result of leaks coming out of
my own White House yeah I mean there's
just so much there and I understand you
have to try to influence your boss in
some way tour but it's troubling that
these are the people doing it I mean at
least John Kelly
he's marine he has elegant he's elegant
he has the gray hairs of experience but
right even Miller all he did was work
for Michele Bachmann he worked for Jeff
Sessions he was Steve bannon's protege
guys only 32 years old and he's
essentially running the country and I'm
glad you mentioned the 32 year old thing
because that's been mentioned online and
the reaction from some has been hey
that's really ages like what's wrong if
he says things that make sense or if he
has good ideas why would you be ageist
in that way I'm not that different
I'm about as old as Stephen Miller and
although it would be lovely to be very
much involved in this way at the White
House I have enough sense of myself and
self-awareness to know that a 32 year
old just doesn't yet have the experience
to be in the position that Stephen
Miller is in which is sort of this de
facto policy leader of the United States
he thinks he does and I'm sure some of
the people around Trump thinks I think
he does I don't think John Kelly thinks
he does but that's a story for a
different day I would know that I'm Way
above above my in above my head I guess
what I'm saying I mean if you're 32
years old you can do great things you
can do great things for the country I
think hope Hicks who's one of the better
ones like 29 yeah but Stephen Miller's
title is senior policy adviser you'd
expect someone a bit older than that
when you're talking about the top
geopolitical and diplomatic decisions
that are being made in the world by the
United States you don't usually want a
32 year old being called the senior
anything that's a red flag and it's not
being ageist and again I'm talking about
someone who is about my age the video
you just finished watching was made
possible by you through the membership
program you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership we
are viewer supported independent media
you can use the coupon
code I voted 17 for a 40% discount off
of your membership